he's dr. Alan sills the NFL's chief
medical officer and neurosurgeon and he
joins us on the program doc thanks for
joining us I was told you have surgery
in about 10 minutes
can they start without you or do you
need to be in there we're gonna have to
make a hard stop on this okay thanks for
having me on I explained what your job
is with the NFL so Dan I help oversee
all the health and safety efforts which
means working with all the club medical
staffs all of our medical committees
certainly our partners at the NFL
Players Association and their medical
staffs as well as all of our research
partners and engineers epidemiologists
and people that help us basically
touching and and helping to execute all
the things that affect health and safety
of players throughout the league when
you start to look at the NFL's plan
coming up this fall and I know it feels
like each week a lot happens you know if
we look back where we were three months
ago who knew we would be where we are
right now and where we're gonna be in
two or three months so is it your job to
sort of look down the road or do you
have to stay in the moment of trying to
adapt to whatever we're seeing on a
daily basis with this virus well I think
there's some both Dan and you made a
great point which I've been telling
people I say it feels like about five
years since we all started quarantine
Ian's sheltering in place it's actually
been probably about a hundred days and
that's the same time interval we have
from downs at the start of our season so
you think about how much we've learned
how much more awareness we have that the
new technologies that are emerging we
expect all that's going to continue in a
put us in a different place so I think
what we have to do is make the best
decisions we can at each stage with the
knowledge in hand but also try to
prepare and remain what the phrase I've
been saying to everybody flexible and
adaptable because in this situation
we're going to be adapting football to
the coronavirus not the virus to
football so it's crucially important
that we have that mindset of flexibility
and adaptability and using that new
knowledge along the way what's your
biggest concern this football season I
think like every one we're dealing with
a novel virus that no one can really
predict and so I think that it's
impossible to know which direction it's
going to take us and and and I think
that's true not just for the NFL but for
the country and for the world so I think
that's why we stay
very regular contact with public health
authorities with the CDC with the White
House Task Force with with public health
authorities in each state in each of our
club markets and we just have to work in
a very collective fashion as we do
what's best for not only just the NFL
but for the public at large are you 100%
confident we're playing football this
fall you know I don't think many of us
can be a hundred percent confident of
anything with regard to this virus I
would say that I'm very optimistic that
where we're tracking we're moving in
that direction but I think throughout
this damn we said look we have to be
cognizant of what's happening from a
public health standpoint the NFL's nine
is gonna put our head down and say we're
charging forward no matter what I think
you saw that with our draft right you
know there are a lot of people that said
well we couldn't or shouldn't do the
draft but we said look we've got this
set of things we'd like to do how can we
do that and do it in concert with what
the current public health
recommendations are and I think we wound
up with with a really unique and special
event that also raised a whole lot of
money for very needed relief effort so
that's the same approach we've got it
we've got to take here we've got to take
really careful look and work very
collaboratively again with our Players
Association their advisors with public
health authorities and make the best and
safest decision for all of our
stakeholders our players coaches fans
everybody that's in the NFL family what
do you think of the NBA plan you know
I've been a very regular contact with
the chief medical officer of the NBA and
all the professional sports leagues we
share with each other regularly our
learnings we're all confronting the
exact same issues and I think that
notionally we all have the same basic
approach to that there are obviously
some subtle nuances and differences from
one league to another just based on
operational issues but I think that
again the NBA is trying to do just what
we've done which is be very thoughtful
to really be cautious to work in a
stepwise fashion to keep everybody as
safe as possible and again we're all
learning from each other in this we talk
not only to each other in North America
but we talk to sports leagues around the
world the Bundesliga the Australian
Football League we're all trying to
share and collaborate and learn from
each other through this event and we
keep talking about well not me but you
know the experts keep talking about this
second wave and I said you know let me
know in the first wave ins because like
we don't we don't know this dock with
when does the first wave end and then
that second wave if it is coming back
so how do you prepare for that yeah I
think you're exactly right you know
there's a saying in the medical
community that all models are wrong but
some are actually useful and I think
that's true here you know that it's
really hard to predict what's going to
happen again I think we just have to be
flexible and adaptable we have to make
the best decisions we can with the
knowledge at hand and as you said that
that's very hard to predict and it's
also varies from region to region you
know what's happening in one part of the
country may be very different from the
other part of the country so I think as
I said we want to make sure we're hand
in glove with our players Association
and with public health authorities to
make the best decisions whatever the
situation on the ground may be at that
time you had a Zico Eliot some other
Cowboys some of the Texans who tested
positive if this was the week of a game
what would be protocol and with Zeke
Elliott and some of these other players
of you know what what safeguards would
be in place here and how long would they
be out so I think obviously I can't
comment specifically on any case but but
in general what our protocols are moving
towards is we want to identify anyone
who's newly infected at the earliest
possible moment and get them isolated
from the rest of the team environment
and again Dan this isn't just about
players this is coaches athletic
trainers strength and conditioning staff
anybody in what we're calling that team
ecosystem we want to identify them at
the earliest phase of infection remove
them from the rest of the environment
get them the appropriate treatment and
then watch and monitor that recovery so
our protocol will detail exactly what we
do at each step with that it's also
really important that we cleared them
appropriately to make sure they're not
infected when they come back in the
screen for things like some of the
cardiac complications that can happen
after kovat infection so we'll have all
that detailed out again we're working
hand in glove with the Players
Association on what that protocol looks
like what would be the minimum that
somebody would have to sit down if they
tested positive well again I think
that's that's based upon public health
guidelines and there's certain
guidelines depending on whether you have
symptoms when the last time your
symptoms were what your test status is
it's hard to give you an exact number
but I mean I think you're looking at
someone missing at least a couple weeks
time after a positive test it's not
going to be a test positive one day and
you're back two or three days later
there's going to be a time interval in
there again our knowledge when that may
continue to evolve a little bit but but
I'd say at a minimum
it's gonna be a couple weeks time what
will facemask look like this
this season will they be any alterations
to them well it's interesting you
mention that you've probably heard that
we've been working with with a group of
engineers to look at some alternative
designs of the face mask with sort of an
extended shield that covers parts of the
face mask I have to say when I first
heard about the idea I thought it was
probably the dumbest thing I heard I
didn't really think it would work but as
I looked at the designs and the
creativity I'm actually incredibly
impressed with that work and so again
we're working together with engineers
from the Players Association and
actually trying some of those models on
different players and getting feedback
and we'll see where that takes us but
I'm optimistic that we may be able to
find us something that's very useful
there again trying to help prevent
respiratory droplets from being spread
around while on the field I know we look
at these athletes and they're young
they're healthy but is a 300-pound
linemen healthy are they more at risk
than somebody who's a running back who
is you know weighs 225 yeah I think
that's something we're still trying to
learn there's still so much about this
virus that we don't know we do know
obviously again age and certain other
factors medical comorbidities that seem
to confirm or risk but how that
translates into an elite athlete
population we just don't know I think
the take-home message is we got to do
all we can to keep everybody safe
whether it's a 300-pound linemen or a
200-pound kicker quarterback we want to
try to mitigate risk for everyone in
there keep them as safe as possible and
as I said if they do become newly
infected get them isolated and treated
appropriately so that we don't spread
around to the rest of the team
go wash your hands good luck in surgery
haha thanks we always do that part and I
appreciate you having me on Thank You
doc that's dr. Alan sills the NFL chief
medical officer and oh by the way a
neurosurgeon